hi I'm Lydia Andrew audio director on
Assassin's Creed syndicate welcome to
1868 London at the height of the
Industrial Revolution the mission you're
about to see happens in Westminster in
central London London is under the
corrupt grip of the Templars who use
street gangs to strike fear into the
working class Jacob Frye will fight to
earn power and respect as he grows his
gang to take control of London from the
underground up these day for a time of
living on your food meal
you're a bully mr. strain and I find I'm
not overly fond of beliefs you are not
on the payroll mr. Frye one opinion is
no concern of mine here Jacob will use
his gang the rooks to confront the
Templars band of thugs in a gang war
streetball our new combat system is more
brutal and focuses on hand to hand and
short weapons the target is escaping
Jacob will pursue him let Brooks battle
it out for the first time ever in an
assassin's creed game we will have fully
systemic vehicles that will impact each
of our core pillars navigation stealth
and fight players will also be able to
ram their pursuers but be aware that
enemies will also be able to use this
against you ramming you off the road or
hijacking your vehicle to allow combat
on top of vehicles we've enabled
carriages to independently follow
targets on the road while the player
takes care of the opposition with our
vehicle damage let's change carriage
before this one falls park
the targets taken refuge in London's
Victoria train station one of the many
historical locations you'll be exploring
teeming with life and gameplay
opportunities
ah
jacob has lost his target and will need
to use the Rope launcher on new
traversal tool which helps you quickly
go up and across buildings the Rope
launcher can also be used as a
horizontal fast travel making navigation
faster and easier the targets getting
away on the train let's see what we can
do to reach him
trains were an important part of the era
and will offer a wealth of new gameplay
opportunities
as per assassins tradition Jacobs all
new weapon the cane includes a hidden
blade
my death accomplishes nothing assessing
guided by our firm hands society will
flourish driven by Speed ingenuity and
efficiency to a glorious future the
people will obey only us we will defend
this new world against criminals like
you
I believe the world has other plans and
that's it for today's demo hope you
enjoyed this III preview of Assassin's
Creed syndicate we can't wait to show
you more soon this is for the players